Das ist wirklich mal wieder papieren zum
Ersten mal wurde ein derartiges bild von den jets eines schwarzen lochs gemacht und schon ist wieder alles anders als gedacht
Der jet ist viel größer als vermutet und das stellt zumindest mal wieder einige theorien in frage und wie bei dem erwarteten
bild von sagittarius a stern ist hier ein absolutes
Riesenteleskop zum einsatz gekommen dass alle rekorde bricht jetzt den klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Es war ein wirklich riesiges radioteleskop nötig um dieses bild zu machen dazu wurden mehr als 20
radioteleskope weltweit zusammen geschaltet und dazu noch das weltraum radioteleskop
radioastronomie mit einem 10 meter reflektor zusammen haben diese teleskope achtung einen durchmesser von
355.000 kilometern das ist nahezu die entfernung zwischen erde und mond
Und die aufnahme die das teleskop jetzt gemacht hat ist auch absolut irre
Denn was hier zu sehen ist hat das forschungsteam absolut nicht. Erwartet es geht. Um das, zentrale supermassereiche schwarze loch in der galaxie ngc
12 75 befindet sich im perseus
galaxienhaufen der etwa 230 millionen lichtjahren entfernung diese galaxie ist als seifert galaxie klassifiziert das
Bedeutet dass sie ein aktives schwarzes loch hat das sich derzeit von
umgebende material ernährt dieses schwarze loch befindet sich in der frühen phase der erzeugung
massiver jets und das bild zeigt etwas völlig unerwartetes
Zitat es stellte sich heraus dass die beobachtete breite. Des jets deutlich größer war als bei den derzeit
favorisierten modellen wo der jet aus der ergo sphäre des schwarzen lochs entsteht ein raum gebiet direkt neben einen sich drehenden
schwarzen loch in das der raum selbst zu einer kreisenden bewegung um das loch geschleppt wird sagte der hauptautor
Gabriele giovanni vom italienischen nationalen institut für astrophysik auf dem bild ist das loch oben in den grünen fleck
Und der jet ist alles was er nach unten aus wirft
Er hat eine länge von achtung drei lichtjahren und dürfte ein bis zwei lichtjahren breit sein und das ist viel breiter als bisher
Angenommen bisher sagt es ja in den animationen und grafiken der nasa zum beispiel eher so aus
Kurz zur erklärung die ergo sphäre um ein schwarzes loch ist die zone in der ein
rotierendes schwarzes loch wie bei einem strudel
Im wasser alles mit in seine drehbewegung mit nimmt auch
den raum nichts kann sich dieser bewegung entziehen auch wenn diese zone noch nicht hinter dem ereignishorizont
Liegt bisher war man davon ausgegangen dass dieser diese zone die quelle auch der jets ist aber
dieser dead hier der sieht ganz anders aus
statt dessen zitat könnte dies bedeuten dass zumindest der äußere teil des sets von der viel größeren
akkretionsscheibe die das schwarze loch umgibt ausgeht dass sagt thomas
sowohl einen von der alte universität in finnland und leiter
Des radio ist von beobachtungs programms noch ist das forschungsteam aber nicht sicher was dieses bild wirklich
Bedeutet unser ergebnis entkräftet noch nicht die aktuellen modelle in denen die jets aus der atmosphäre
Gestartet werden aber es gibt den theoretikern hoffentlich einen einblick in die jets struktur in der nähe des abschlusses
Um die modelle zu entwickeln
Das sagt ja wohl einen so oder so wird man sich gedanken über die jets und deren entstehung machen müssen ich bin
Auf die ergebnisse sehr gespannt wenn er als erstes neues zum thema schwarze löcher und deren jets und zu allen anderen themen erfahren wollt dann
Hättet hier meine telefonnummer bei whatsapp dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen andern vom neuesten video garantiert und zur begrüßung
Da gibt es ein kleines goodie einfach hier draufklicken und natürlich nicht das abo mit der
Genau glocke vergessen hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch. Draufklicken das rätsel der
supermassereichen schwarzen löcher ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dann